New York you're talking on a base of 19
million so number of positive cases up
to 86 69 92 thousand total in the state
predominantly in New York City but you
see Westchester and Nassau which by
percentage is a troubling number
remember New York City so much larger
than Bush's and Nassau Suffolk so those
numbers are concerning and we're
watching those you don't see in Nassau
County 1,000 new cases Suffolk County
1141 new cases that is that is trouble
troubling news number of counties you
see the entire state every county in the
state now has reported a coronavirus
case we said it was going to march
across the state have also made the
point to my colleagues on every phone
call I deal with the other governors the
other officials I say it's go to march
across the country it is false comfort
to say well we are we are a rural
community we don't have the density of
New York City that is a false comfort
you have counties in New York State
where you have more cows than people New
York State don't think of just New York
City upstate New York is a rural
community and you see that it's not just
urban areas its suburban areas
that's Westchester Nassau Suffolk
comparable to suburban communities all
across this country and we have rural
communities that are comparable to rural
communities all across this country in
many ways New York State is a microcosm
of the United States and that's why I
believe it's going to be illustrative
for the rest of this nation as to what's
going to happen corrode hospitalizations
as I said ninety two thousand tested
positive 13,000 currently hospitalized
that's up eleven hundred three thousand
ICU patients that's up three hundred
seventy four hundred patients discharged
that's up 1292 that's good news number
of people going to the hospitals going
up number of people coming out of the
hospital is going up number of deaths up
to twenty three seventy three up from
nineteen forty one looking for a
trendline the trendline is still
basically up total new hospitalizations
trendline of ICU admissions is still up
certainly a couple of small deviations
but the line is up number of intubations
is up but if you want to take an
optimistic view you could start to see a
plateauing in the number of intubations
but the statisticians tell me that's an
optimistic view number of daily
discharged was going way up that's
people going in people going out
challenge is still at the apex that's
what this is been all about for every
system in this country now everyone is
basically waging the same battle
different timeframes different numbers
different percentages but it's the same
battle when you hit the apex which is
the highest rate of infection highest
number of people coming into the
hospital system can you handle that
number can you handle the height of the
impact on the hospital system which is
at the apex of the curve
we call that the Battle of the
mountaintop at least I call it the
Battle of the mountaintop questions
people keep asking which are the right
questions well when is the apex it
depends on what model you use what model
you follow we follow all the models it's
anywhere from 7 to 21 to 30 days
depending on what model you look at well
how can you have that variable seven to
thirty days it depends on how that model
rates how effective social distancing is
right the variable is the models that
think social distancing is going to be
more effective at slowing the rate have
a longer time frame for the apex those
models that discount the social
distancing they have a shorter time
frame for the apex it makes it difficult
to plan frankly because seven to thirty
days is a long window and we are
literally planning on a day-to-day basis
deploying assets on a day to day basis
we believe it is closer to the shorter
end of the range with our in-house
people looking at the professional
modeling that's being done how many beds
will you need at the apex between 70 and
110 thousand again that is a broad range
again that's one of the frustrations
trying to plan for this right now we
have 53,000 statewide we have only
36,000 downstate remember that and this
is primarily a downstate issue so by any
estimate we don't have a number the
number of beds but again we've taken
extraordinary measures every Hospital by
mandate has to add a 50% increase and
they have all done that we're setting up
extra facilities which we've been
talking about we've been shifting
patients from
state hospitals to upstate hospitals and
that is continuing when does this end
you have projection models that have us
hitting the apex coming down from the
apex models very at how quickly you come
down from the apex but they all
basically say you come down from the
apex quickly and then some models have
it flattening out but flattening out for
a period of time models have it
flattening out and continuing through
the summer
how many lives lost there's only one
model that we look at that has the
number of projected deaths which is the
eye hme model which is funded by the
Gates Foundation and we thank the Gates
Foundation for the national service that
they've done but that is the model that
suggests approximately 93 thousand
deaths across the country that's the
model that I believe dr. pouchy was
referring to when he said about 100,000
deaths by that New York would be about
16,000 deaths by that model when we're
doing this planning and we're doing our
deployment the theory is the chain is
only as strong as the weakest link right
so that's true for the hospital system
we have about give or take 180 hospitals
that we are focusing on here in this
state the hospitals that will have the
greatest issue will be those hospitals
that are usually the most stress in most
stressed in normal circumstances right
so if the hospitals before this were
under stress you then add this crisis on
top of that those are the hospitals that
one would expect to see struggling first
that's also true for the entire hospital
system you know we talked about beds we
talked about staff we talked about
supplies but the truth is you need all
three of those things to provide any
care a bed without a staff without staff
doesn't do anything a bed and staff
without supplies doesn't do anything so
you need all three of those components
to work to have a situation where
someone can I actually get care in terms
of beds those are the easiest to find
and we're constructing additional
facilities we're now going to start at
the Brooklyn cruise terminal obviously
in Brooklyn New York New York City it's
expected to open this week 750 beds
we're taking a office of mental health
facility in Staten Island and converting
it to a covered only hospital so on beds
we are in relatively good shape because
a bed is a bed right a bed is a question
of a structure push comes to shove we
can acquire dorms we can acquire hotels
we can acquire physical structures with
beds in them of those three components
bed staff supplies are I personally am
least worried about bed capacity we have
2,500 beds at Javits we have a thousand
beds on the naval ship Comfort beds we
can find not easy but we can find them
the harder components are the staff and
the supplies which is what we've been
talking about on the staff we're
continuing to shift staff from the
upstate hospitals that are less impacted
to downstate hospitals
we've requested out of state healthcare
workers god bless america
21,000 people have volunteered from out
of state to come into New York State I
thank them I thank their patriotism
I thank their
dedication and passion to their mission
of public health these are beautiful
generous people and New Yorkers will
return the favor
New Yorkers will return the favor this
is going to affect every place in this
country we are in some ways the first
major encounter we're learning
we'll get the experience and we will
return the favor when your community
needs help
New Yorkers will be there and you have
my personal word on that and it's also
the New York tradition when there's been
a hurricane or there's been a flood or
Hurricane Katrina New Yorkers are the
first ones in their cars to go anywhere
in this nation that needs help and I
will be the first one in my car to go
wherever this nation needs help as soon
as we get past this I will never forget
how people of course this country came
to the aid of New Yorkers when they
needed it and I deeply appreciate it
we have 85,000 volunteers now in total
which are being deployed to the
hospitals so they can find staff that
works for them supplies are an ongoing
challenge the PPE is an ongoing
challenge the gowns the gloves and the
ventilators first of all we have of the
first time ever a hospital by Hospital
survey that will be done on a nightly
basis of exactly what they have as I
said we're coordinating the health care
system in a way it's never been
coordinated before rather than having
all these regional systems and public
systems private systems etc we have a
central stockpile we are asking all the
hospitals to contribute what they have
to that central stockpile and then we
will disperse on a need basis you know
some hospitals have
more supplies than they're using we're
saying you don't hoard supplies let's
put all the supplies in a central
stockpile and then we will draw down
from the central stockpile and we will
monitor this literally on a daily basis
on I'm also asking on supplies I don't
have a New York defense production act
right governor can't say to a company we
need you to manufacture this but I ask
businesses just to think about the
situation we're in a possible
opportunity
it is the cruelest irony that this
nation is now dependent on China for
production of many of these products
many of these products in the normal
marketplace were being produced in China
and now you have everyone shopping China
for PPE gowns ventilators the gowns the
gloves are not complicated components to
manufacture the gowns are Tyvek or paper
material if you are a manufacturer who
can convert to make these products and
make them quickly they are not
complicated products the FDA lists the
specifications for these products on
their website if you have the capacity
to make these products we will purchase
them and we will pay a premium and we
will pay to convert or transition your
manufacturing facility to a facility
that can do this but we need it like now
you know we're not talking about two
months three months four months we need
these materials now that's the stress I
understand that but if you are in the
garment
Manufacturing business if you have
machinery that can cut a pattern you
know a coverall you're not making a
fashion forward fitted garment right
these are relatively straightforward
components so if you can do it it's a
business opportunity it is the state
need it's a national need please contact
us we'll work with you will work with
you quickly there'll be no bureaucracy
no red tape and we'll finance
we're not asking for a favor from these
businesses will finance what you need in
terms of transitioning and we'll buy the
product and I will pay a premium because
we need it and this is a number for the
Empire State Development Corporation
which is handling this task in terms of
ventilators we released 400 ventilators
- last night - the New York City Health
and Hospitals corporation we released
200 to Long Island and Westchester as I
said you see that those growing numbers
in Nassau and Suffolk and that is
starting to stress that healthcare
system so we release those ventilators
last night at the current burn rate we
have about six days of ventilators in
our stockpile meaning if the rate of
usage the rate of people coming into
hospitals who need ventilators if that
rate continues in our stockpile we have
about six days now if the apex happens
within that timeframe
if the apex increases if the apex is
longer we have an issue with ventilators
these numbers by the way are also going
to be compiled every night there's a
difference of opinion I'm
anyone you need will need what we need
you know I have no desire to acquire
more ventilators than we need the way we
basically are acquiring ventilators is
the state is buying them they are very
expensive and the state is broke so I
have no desire to buy more ventilators
than we need but we need what we need if
a person comes in and needs a ventilator
and you don't have a ventilator the
person dies that's the blunt equation
here and right now we have a a burn rate
that would suggest we have about six
days in the stockpile but but we are
taking all sorts of extraordinary
measures I've spoken to health people
all across the nation doctors dierker's
and all sorts of research and we have
extraordinary measures in place that can
make a difference if we run into a real
ventilator shortage first we know where
all the ventilators are in the state of
New York by hospital if we have a
problem in any hospital we are going to
take the ventilators that are not needed
from the Upstate hospitals and transport
them to downstate New York or the
hospitals that do need them which again
more and more are going to be on Long
Island and then we'll return them or
we'll figure out the finances of it and
make those hospitals holes we're also
increasing the number of ventilators by
ending all elective surgeries if you
don't need an elective surgery a
hospital cannot perform it if it's not
critical that's freeing up ventilators
we're also using anesthesia machine
ventilators without the anesthesia
obviously but using them as ventilators
we're also so called splitting
ventilators we put out a protocol all
the hospitals of practicing that now one
ventilator two sets of tubes can do to
patients it's not easy it's not ideal
but it's better than nothing we're also
converting what's close BiPAP machine
which or again don't have the same force
as a ventilator but on an emergency
basis some research has been done that
says they could be suitable we are also
still in the business of looking for
ventilators to buy ventilators it's too
late to ask a company to make them in
any way that would work for our
timeframe you look at our timeframe 7
days to 30 days no one is going to be
able to make a ventilator for you in
that period of time
nationwide parts of the country that
have a later curve yes if you give a
company two months three months they can
ramp up production but not on our not on
our curve so we have to find ventilators
that we can buy and we're still doing
that and again the main place is China
we're converting the BiPAP machines this
has not been done before but north well
which is one of our premier healthcare
systems has developed the protocol and
they're teaching the other hospitals now
how to do it we just bought 3,000 BiPAP
machines and 750 came in yesterday so
yes the burn rate of ventilators is
troubling and six days of ventilators in
the stockpile is troubling but we have
all these extraordinary measures that I
believe if push comes to shove will put
us in fairly good shape I don't want to
say yet I'm confident and it depends on
how many we need but I can say with
confidence we have researched every
possibility every idea every measure you
can possibly take to find ventilators
this state has done that I can that I
can promise you
we're also going to open the healthcare
exchange enrollment period through May
15th
we have about 96% of the people in this
data covered with health insurance if
you're not covered we're extending the
enrollment period to May 15th
please get covered you can go to the New
York state of health website and sign up
my brother my little brother brother
Christopher tested positive for corona
virus a lot of people are concerned
about him obviously people in my family
but even beyond that you know New
Yorkers are very compassionate and many
people ask me about Chris and how's he
doing not just for himself but we keep
talking about this coronavirus
coronavirus karana virus I'm afraid of
it I'm anxious about it what does it
actually mean okay your brother has it
how's he doing so a lot of people ask me
that question
and I talked to him quite frequently and
he is doing okay and I checked in with
him this morning and asked him how he
was feeling and he was up and spry and
much his normal self I invited him to
join us for a couple of minutes if he
was up to it this morning and I think he
said that he was in a position to join
us and I asked him to join us by video
if he's available there he is with his
hat cool more prime time say hello to
get there I saw it I saw it's hard to
miss you're looking let's get after it
let's get after it I love that saying
you're looking fit and fine many people
are asking about you
I'll tell you the truth everyone I
talked to was asking about you and how
you're doing and how you're handling it
and how you feel
Cara's here by the way she's working
with me now she's working on supplies
so she says hello so how are you feeling
I love Cara you have great kids
there's there's no better way to measure
it with what you've actually met in the
world
it's where your daughters are great and
I'm not surprised to help them make me
proud of the pendant thank God the next
generation better than one I've brought
it into this I'm pretty well it's
considered this is very tough I get it
now I've now become part of this group
of people who have this virus and
they're reaching out to friends and
people or new friends they have this
innate constant fever and it's tough
look like you've been cutting your own
hair which but it's gonna be a long I'm
more comfortable and I've learned that I
see people out you gotta rest because
your body has this Bieber because it's
fighting the virus and you've got a
chill I'm very lucky I have a wife who
loves me who's keeping me through I got
a nice place two things have been very
smart and ruining how they can reach out
and help before without contact a lot of
people are fighting this alone and I
can't imagine it I can barely you know
together and I have everything done very
look there are a lot of people who are
in a bad way and they're reaching out to
me and I feel for them so we're in a
real fight and we really do have to
remember our connections to each other
because otherwise they'll be no wait
you're on right you're on day two yeah I
really
gnosis may be psychosomatic
and those rygaards spelled like rigors
alright you're us but it was like out of
a movie I'll tell you I had nation or
scene you came to me an agreement to had
on a very interesting la outfit and you
were dancing in the dreaming and you
were waving a wand and saying I wish I
could wave my wand and make this go away
and then you spun around and you passed
away well that says there's a lot of a
metaphorical reality now I thank you for
sharing that with us kind of use
obviously obviously the fever has
affected your mental capacity and so you
you still have a fever D of a fever
today I don't even write this really
well you look good yet I have to tell
you comparatively you look good well
first of all I appreciate to your
audience that it's concerned about how I
look phase in several time and you
didn't like my hair you thought that I
was giving a bit of survival I think I'm
good you look good you sound good I have
I know that sometimes we joke I'm not
going to do that today you know rule one
is never hit a brother when he's down
and you're literally in the basement so
I'm gonna refrain from any rebuttal
today the you disco
is probably the best fit because when
I'm healthy you know what happens you
need to go toe to toe and I'm Melton so
really if I were you now's the time to
strike
yeah but see that you maybe get thick I
would come right now no I'm not gonna
forget all the jokes no raise my fever
no look first I have no doubt that you
would hit me when I'm down
that's the difference between us and
that is my boy I that's not who I am
I'm hadn't made any jokes I didn't it
was not a joke
some people misinterpreted what I said I
said that I was going to send you a book
because I know he's just walking around
the basement there that I was gonna send
you a book on a beginner's guide to
start bass-fishing but that's only
because you know you normally fish for
porgies and it's totally different to
fish with striped bass than poor guys I
was never saying anything that was in
any way offensive
well I preached I loved fish my favorite
you're the only person I've ever known
fishes in all white because you have no
expectation of getting any or any type
of fish which has been great training
for the virus existence pretty much the
entire time of them yes I believe you
can fish and still stay neat and clean
I'll tell you this I love bees I think
you should have one in three a yes I
have been I know you have a note oh yes
sorry
yes it's sort of like the way you have a
show yes I do a briefing you have Cuomo
prime time I have Cuomo all the time
that's the difference yes yes it is a
good looking at and one hour a day I
work 23 hours a day that's like the
mathematical balance but anyway that's
my job
I do believe this is going to be a great
public service in
ironic way people are curious about
coronavirus what does it mean what
happens if I get one you get the virus
you living it showing it doing it doing
the show reporting on how you feel
reporting on what you're doing I think
it really takes it demystifies this it
takes a lot of the unknown out of the
equation
and I know it's a terrible unfortunate
circumstance for you but think about it
from a journalistic point of view of
public service point of view you are
answering questions for millions of
Americans if I get it what happens what
do i do what do I look like how about my
family by the way
best news is thank God your family
doesn't show any symptoms knock Formica
yeah because if your wife had any
symptoms you would be in the basement
for a lot longer than this virus would
keep you in the basement my brother
but let me tell you I've always been
emotionally dependent on my wife but now
I don't eat without Christine that's if
the kids won't come in take a picture
with it is that a religious issue or is
that like a canine anything to you I get
a text message they are very proud of
you and what you're doing I know how
hard this is for you I know it's
frustrating when you can't control what
you need and you know what you need and
you know how important it is and you
can't get and that is very tough and
I've watched it in real time with you
and I can tell people of course I'm your
brother I'll never be objective about
you my favorite guy but I've never seen
you work harder than now and I've
never seen you have this kind of
desperation to source equipment and
you're drawn in from everybody you know
and you've done everything you can to
stay positive with the federal
government and that is so important
right now and you're doing everything
you can unfortunately look what's one of
the big lessons in life that Bob boys
used to tell us certain things you're
not gonna be able to control certain
things are going to happen this virus is
one of them
it happened it's gonna run its course
you guys can't put a number on it I know
there's a huge temptation to do it I
know you're using the models I talked to
dr. Falchi and all the different experts
people want timing but we got to be
realistic we don't know how long it's
gonna last
we only know what we control which is
staying away from one another and if we
do that well things will go better but
sometimes in life you got to ride it out
and when one of those experiences now
people will remember this period maybe
more than any other period and there are
lives and people will be remembered for
how they stepped up right now and what
they did and what they didn't do and I'm
very proud of you big brother yeah well
look I've said I've said at this
briefing you know this is a
transformative moment for the state for
the country I believe that I also
believe it's a moment where you really
see what people are made of you know
when when the pressure is on that's when
you see all the cracks and you see all
the strength it's nice too it's easy to
be nice when everything is nice but when
when the pressure is really on and for
you when they told you you tested
positive you know a lot of people's
instinct would have been to get in bed
pull the covers over your head and just
lay there for you to get up do that show
share with people that is a strength and
a character strength that is really
incredible and you know we we joke a lot
but the strength and you showed here and
the dedication to journalism and your
skill and your ability to make this okay
for people and to communicate it you can
do the coronavirus have
the coronavirus but you know life goes
on I've been saying a thousand times 80%
of the people get it and they will self
resolve you know but you're showing that
and not many people would have stood up
the way you you have stood up and I am
I've always been proud of you you know
that on a basic level not only do I love
you I've always been proud of you but
I've never been prouder of you than I am
right now you go get some rest I love
you
everybody loves you this is gonna be
fine you're gonna get through it and
you're gonna do a beautiful public
service in the mean time and I'm proud
of you and then we'll go fishing we'll
have a drink and we'll laugh about it go
get some rest
thank you for taking the temperature and
very nice and saying virus they are
right you're right well and I hear all
the advice I love you thank you for
letting me join today I'll enjoy
watching this now that I know it's
particular thing I'll watch it every day
because I'm stuck in the basement thank
you thank you for saying such loving
supportive things rule one never hit a
brother when he's down in the basement
love you in the basement in the basement
love you questions let's do the
coronavirus questions and many local
questions will do afterwards would you
be interested in placing mandatory
curfews in places that aren't interested
in obeying social distancing rules yeah
well it would depend on what the
question is would I be open to curfews
it depends on what their problem is what
this situation is and what they're
trying to solve and we'd have to talk
through it sorry I have to understand
what they put the theory of their action
is reports if there's only a handful of
people in the comfort at this point can
you give us some update of how many
patients are in the ship as well as in
Javits Center at this point I do not
have the numbers Jessie but I can get
for you those two facilities are
operated by the federal government as
you know they're for non covert patients
only the theory is that the non kovat
patients would come out of hospitals
freeing up more beds in the hospitals
for covered patients and that the jabots
and the comfort would be a overflow
valve for that the federal government
determines who comes in by their
protocol and but I have to get the
numbers I don't have the numbers they
could you would need the federal
government to allow you to have Jeff
look Javits Center can do the Javits and
Comfort can do whatever the military
allows them to I understand on the
Comfort they don't want to bring in
Kovac patients because that's an entire
ship how do you disinfect the ship
afterwards and that's a complicated
situation Javits you could convert to a
covert facility it would require the
federal government to allow it I don't
know what kind of medical staff Cove
adverse is NaN Colvin maybe dr. Zucker
wouldn't know so it it really depends on
their clinical condition the the Kovac
patients who are recovering are in their
convalescent phase and so yeah they
should be getting better and needs some
respiratory support from the standpoint
of chess PT and and nursing care more
than anything else and and the
non-covered patients obviously depends
on what their medical condition is but
obviously those individuals would have
to be in relatively stable condition
I'm just wondering if that's true and
that would have any bearing any impact
on the models and the projections that
we're using in the United States the
it's an interesting question part of
what we do not do the models in-house
right we review the models but we don't
do the models we have McKinsey does
models Cornell Weill does models etc
it's a whole art form unto itself the
modelers will tell you they use wuhan
data especially when they're trying to
calibrate the rate of spread and the
effect of social isolation but they also
have a lot of data post China that they
are relying on you have South Korea you
have the rate of spread now here so you
raise a good point if the China data was
wrong
might it influence the model yes but the
model isn't solely dependent on that
data either
[Music]
did New York receive any faulty
ventilators from the federal government
we've received the state overall city in
the state received 4400 we have
distributed many of them I have not
heard of any faulty this was an article
in the LA Times out in California it was
reported that some of the ventilators
that were sent to them by the federal
government were faulty and the
explanation is apparently you have to
run ventilators ever so often it's not
unlike a car battery not that this is my
particular area of expertise admittedly
and so that was what they chalked that
issue up to in New York when we saw that
report we begun to review our own
stockpile we're in the process of doing
that now of the ventilators we got from
the feds and we haven't seen a problem
so far you know where the federal
government is very aware of our
situation I spoke to the president this
morning I worked with the vice president
at the White House staff etc I don't
think the federal government is in a
position to provide ventilators to the
extent the nation may need them you know
I don't think it's a question that the
ventas federal government has
ventilators that they're not
distributing they may have bent the
ladders that they're not distributing
now on the same theory that I'm not
distributing all of our ventilators now
because you have a stockpile right state
is a stockpile federal government has a
stockpile concept of a stockpile is you
stockpile until you need it
but I I don't know if they have more in
the stockpile I know that the ventilator
availability is just a problem for
everyone you're 50 States competing for
it you're the federal government trying
to buy it I don't know what their
capacity is in their stockpile but I
wouldn't it all be surprised if they
don't have enough in their stockpile to
provide for all
communities that need it that's why our
attitude here is you know we're on our
own I will ask the federal government if
we get to that point I'll ask them I'll
plead I'll do whatever I have to do to
get ventilators from the federal
government but that's why we're also
taking all those extraordinary measures
ourselves just assume you are on your
own in life right and that's the
operating assumption but having said
that I am sure the federal government
would do anything they can do to help
there has been nothing in our
relationship that would suggest they
wouldn't do what they can do to help the
question is what can they do I don't
know the answer to that question no I
think you're past that point now because
you just can't find the product exact
level machines to regular ventilator
machines compared to leaders by path
versus a ventilator it's a great
question
I would love to respond to it except I
have no idea how a BiPAP relates to a
ventilator
besides the generic comment that the
BiPAP does not have the same level of
force doesn't pump as much air as a
ventilator beyond that I do not know but
dr. Zucker may know that was a the the
BiPAP systems are are basically they
don't have as much energy to push air in
and that the the ventilators have many
more capabilities of doing different
types of respiratory support but the
BiPAP machine will be able to help many
individuals once you convert over
for relatively minor cases well I think
that you know this is a condition which
is gonna change as someone gets either
better or worse and I think sometimes
people think you put them on one machine
and then they stay on that machine but
you can move things around you can put
someone on a ventilator start to get
better and then you can sort of switch
them to a BiPAP machine and that may
provide the support that they need at
that point in time and then you can move
it to the next phase as well so it's not
a stagnant situation ventilate has more
variability than the bypass machine this
is not an ideal situation and this is
not a standard metal medical protocol
right everybody's made that clear to me
in a perfect world everybody would have
a ventilator and that's our first goal
and it's always been our goal and you
know I've been talking about ventilators
since this thing started but if we if we
hit that apex and we run out of
ventilators then on the theory of you do
whatever you can do then we have all
those series of measures take the
ventilators from hospitals that don't
need them splitting the ventilator so
you double the capacity of a ventilator
use a BiPAP machine on a patient - you
can use a BiPAP machine all of those
measures go into effect because you have
no option right you're going to be in a
situation with literally if the person
doesn't have a ventilator they die you
don't have a ventilator then come up
with plan b c d e f G H and that's what
we have done by the way we even have a
plan for the I showed you the handheld
rubber ventilator that's just a bladder
that is manually operated and we
purchased 7,000 of those
President Trump said this morning that
New York was had gotten a late start
that it had gotten far more supplies in
that and then in the next breath said
that Cuomo was working hard how do you
make a sense of the president's
criticism of the state and praise of you
I don't know I don't know I don't know
how you square those two statements I
don't know that you can square those two
statements got a late start on supplies
we started purchasing and we probably
will have wound up purchasing more than
any state in the country I will bet you
dollars to doughnuts we want to buying
more ventilators than any state in the
country so we were very aggressive from
day one as you know and again that's on
the assumption that the state's each
state is supposed to be managing this
situation but I thank him for his good
words that he thinks I'm doing a good
job we're doing the best we can with all
the special populations in prisons and
nursing homes and homeless shelters what
happens after that if tenants aren't
paying their rent should landlords let's
see where we are after 90 days you know
a lot of these situations what do we do
about rent after 90 days what do we do
about income after 90 days what do we do
about infrastructure after 90 days you
know we so much of this is changing and
fluid I don't think anyone can sit here
and tell you what the right plan is for
any of these areas 90 days from now I
just want to get to 90 days from now and
get their healthy and then we'll handle
whatever we have to handle
we have not received you remember Jim
Jim doctor maybe we will have to check
whether they're gonna be delayed because
there have been issues of course with
shipping internationally right now but
we'll get back to you on the exact
answer of where they are we have about
2,200 ventilators in the stockpile
that's what we have yes
2200 ventilators the number of people
who come in per night who need a
ventilator is somewhere in the range
right because it's a little different
every night but if you wanted to be safe
you'd say like 350 350 people come in
every night who need a ventilator so
2,200 you see disappears very quickly
what do you do try to buy more
ventilators and then Plan B Plan C plan
D and that's what we've laid out there
is no state and no country that has done
anything to provide ventilators that we
are not doing we've literally looked at
everything that Italy did China did
South Korea did every other state we're
doing more than any other state or
country has ever tried to do in terms of
backup contingency plans and you know
beyond that every day we try to find
more buy more and be more creative who
has the answer question
have I changed no I defy change my kids
will tell you that Carlo will tell you
that they have been trying to get me to
change for many years they have tried to
teach me for many years
intellectually I think I'm open to
growth and change I just have trouble
doing it in practicality I think it'll
change me I think it'll change me this
is very it's incredibly hard it's
incredibly difficult
my brother touched on it you know I take
my job very seriously
and I take my responsibilities very
seriously and I don't make excuses i I
don't I don't if I fail I fail you know
if something breaks or something doesn't
work that's on me
I see those number of deaths every day
and I take that personally and I feel
the pain that families are feeling and
I'm doing everything I can but people
are still dying and that is very hurtful
and humbling and painful just painful
and this is a long time to be under that
level of pain what do you look like when
you come out the other side I don't know
I don't know
yeah I don't know if they have looked
into it but if they haven't we will
[Music]
guess well no and yes no to the first
part yes to the sec regard have we
looked at facts and figures we've
discussed this for two years intensively
there's been all sorts of conversations
as you know I had a meeting in this room
with all the interested parties like ten
days ago yes yeah everyone has been
looking at the facts and figures and
discussing and debating and analyzing
and there's been a is a range of opinion
as you know on most matters there's a
range of opinion and the bail reform
that we did last year I'm very proud of
because it was discriminatory in effect
if not in and then impact and I think we
made the right change now and I think
the improvements we made this year the
right ones also
well essential projects are projects
that our public works by and large that
the state needs and the city needs you
know after this is over we're going to
have to get back to work and we're gonna
have to have an economy that functions
and having infrastructure isn't an
essential part of that and a lot of
these projects once you start you can't
just stop you know
those airports are still functioning
planes are still coming in and LaGuardia
is a whole configuration of physical
barriers and alternative routes pending
construction so a project like that
would be very very difficult to freeze
and then unfreeze anyone who has
enhanced a question okay
how do you make the decision on whether
it's basically on finances so I would
ask Robert mihika what he thinks we're
gonna look at access to the market
access to the market is pretty limited
right now we're gonna be borrowing to
deal with the short-term revenue
shortfall but by next September next
October we'll look at the state's
finances at that point look at our
access to the market and then make a
determination then it's hard to tell how
likely is it gonna be that the economy's
gonna return to where it is next October
it's your guess I'm not sure yet right
we're gonna look at what what the market
will allow us tomorrow how much we have
in reserve and make that determination
at this time right the shortfall between
April and July 15th is gonna be is 10
billion dollars so it'll be somewhere
between you know between that number we
have some access to reserves that we
have so we'll make the determination
then that the legislature and the
executive got this budget or or getting
this budget done with all the
initiatives that are in this budget is
an extraordinary feat of government
accomplishment and I praise speaker
Heastie
and Senate leader Andrea stewart-cousins
and every member of the legislature you
know would have been very easy to say oh
this is an extraordinary year let's just
do the bare minimum and go home
they said the opposite they said we have
a lot of needs there are a lot of issues
that need to be addressed and they
stepped up to the plate and they did it
you look at that list of initiatives
that are in this budget you can put that
budget against any budget that I have
done in any normal year and it would be
a great budget that it was done this
year is really extraordinary
so I praise them for that anything I
said that wrong incorrect misstated
don't be shy now is the time
make the point that on bail while there
are additional crimes that our bail
eligible that's what they are bail
eligible so it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's going to translate into more
people and I believe the effective date
is 90 days from now so it takes into
consideration the current circumstance
that we find ourselves in there were 115
crimes that we moved to be alternate to
bail eligible so things like remote
tracking and treatment and other things
so there was a heavy emphasis on that as
well in the bail reform bill thank you
guys stay safe stay stay safe social
distance did the MRT recommendations get
many of the amazing recommendations were
are in the budget which will be enacted
if legislature goes forward we have the
ability to delay them in the budget so
we have so the effective dates can be
changed to you 18 years old again